The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Continuing our discussion of
acid-base theory,
I have just drawn here on the
board for you the structure of a
popular indicator molecule.
Indicator molecules are used
for titrations.
And titrations will be of focus
of today's lecture.
This is the indicator molecule,
phenolphthalein.
It is easier to draw this
molecular structure than it is
to spell phenolphthalein,
but you should know how to do
both of these things,
or at least recognize them.
Now, how do indicator molecules
work?
Well, during a titration,
you are mixing chemicals in a
way that leads to a changing pH
throughout the experiment.
And an indicator molecule like
phenolphthalein is,
in fact, a Bronsted acid.
And, if you inspect the
structure that I have drawn here
for phenolphthalein,
you should be able to begin to
understand just how it is that a
molecule like this can serve as
a Bronsted acid.
If I write out the formula,
you will see that we have quite
a number of carbons and
hydrogens in the molecule.
And we have oxygens as well.
Those are the three elements
present in a phenolphthalein
molecule.
And two of the hydrogens in
this molecule possess Bronsted
acidity that makes them valuable
for the function of this system
as an indicator molecule.
And what happens is when you
have this in solution at low pH,
it is in this form.
It is neutral.
And then, as you begin to raise
the pH, at some point a base
that has a lone pair of
electrons comes along and takes
one of these two protons in a
molecule, either this one or
this one.
Those two protons are
equivalent.
And what I am now going to draw
is a sequence of arrows
representing the electronic flow
in the phenolphthalein molecule
that occurs when H plus
is transferred over to the base
with its lone pair of electrons.
So, I am starting these arrows
at pairs of electrons and I am
showing the flow of how they
move.
And this is a pretty
interesting rearrangement
because it is complicated.
It is an electronic
rearrangement that is
transmitted through this
molecule such that here in the
center, this four coordinate or
sp three hybridized
carbon, which is bonded to this
oxygen, has a pair of electrons
that migrates to it.
And, if I draw now the product
of this reaction,
what you should be able to see
quite clearly --
And I am not always explicitly
drawing out the lone pairs of
electrons on each of the
electronegative oxygen atoms in
the molecule,
but the sequence of double
bonds and single bonds in the
molecule has been altered in a
profound manner because of the
base coming along and removing a
proton from one of these
peripheral oxygens,
namely, that one here.
So, we have now a singly
negatively charged system.
And that charge is balanced,
over here, by the base that has
the proton attached to it.
That is the structure-function
relationship that is typical of
indicator molecules.
And indicator molecules can
either be naturally occurring,
as they are in some plants.
Or, alternatively,
they can be molecules that are
synthesized to respond to
factors like pH in a given way
that might be desired.
And, in the case of
phenolphthalein,
this change takes place between
8.2 to 10.0 pH units.
And the color change associated
with this is colorless to pink.
Looking at the structure of the
anionic form of the
phenolphthalein molecule that
results from its deprotonation,
what you can see is that this
sp three hybridized
carbon atom at the center of the
molecule, which in the neutral
form is acting as an insulator,
preventing the pi-systems of
the three six-member rings from
communicating,
is converted into a
three-coordinate sp two
hybridized carbon atom here at
the center, --
and provides a conduit for a
communication between the
pi-systems of the three
six-membered substituted benzene
rings that are in this molecule.
And that change in electronic
structure is what leads to the
production of this pink
Chromaphor in the anionic
deprotonated form of a
phenolphthalein molecule that is
important at high pH.
All you have to do,
in fact, is to change the
substituents on this molecule in
order to get a response at a
different pH value.
Bromothymol blue is an
indicator with a structure
similar to that of
phenolphthalein,
but with a sulfur here in place
of this carbon.
And in bromothymol blue,
we also have some isopropyl and
bromine substituents on the
aromatic rings.
And that modifies its
properties such that it goes
from yellow to blue as the pH
rises above 6.0 to about a value
of 7.6.
So, if you go to a textbook and
look in a table of indicator
molecules, you will be able to
select an indicator that is
appropriate for a particular
type of titration.
And just to give you a very
simple schematic of a classic
type of titration,
I am going to show you here --
-- the type of system that you
may need to think about in
connection with this next
problem set.
And it is a system like this,
where we have a flask down here
at the bottom that contains,
initially, some volume of a
weak acid.
And that weak acid might be,
for example,
acetic acid,
as we talked about last time.
And we will say,
for example,
that this could be 0.1 molar CH
three COOH.
That is acetic acid.
And the calculation that we
left off with at the end of last
hour is one that we will get to
solving today that had to do
with what is the pH of a tenth
molar acetic acid solution in
water?
Or, in other words,
what is the pH of this solution
down here containing the acetic
acid at the beginning of this
titration that we are going to
carry out.
We might have a weak acid down
here.
We might also have our
indicator present,
so that we will see a color
change when we pass through a
particular pH.
And we are going to make the pH
rise by putting into this
burette here,
which will allow us to control
a dropwise addition of a strong
base solution that we are going
to add in and slowly neutralize
our acetic acid that is down
here at the bottom.
So, this is strong base.
And, for example,
that might be tenth molar
sodium hydroxide.
So, there is a typical
titration.
And, if you think about it,
because we are adding one
solution to another,
we are going to have a
constantly changing volume in
this bottom solution throughout
the experiment.
And so ultimately what we are
going to be interested in,
in our questions such as the
following, as the volume
increases --
And we will give the volume,
for the purposes of today's
lecture, the symbol the lower
case letter m -- As the volume
increases, what happens to the
pH?
We know that we are using a
strong base to neutralize an
acid, so the pH is going to
start out low and somehow is
going to rise.
But what if we wanted to
predict the mathematical form of
the rise in pH as a function of
this increasing volume of the
solution?
Then we would have to have some
equations that would be useful
for describing this physical
property as a function of this
increasing volume.
This is what we often want to
be able to do in chemistry.
We want to be able to describe
properties that change either as
a function of time or as a
function of some other variable,
here volume,
in a titration.
And we want to be able to see
if we can come up with a set of
equations that would predict
that change as a function of
this variable that is changing.
And, in order to do that,
here, I am going to first point
out that we can put together
some titration equations.
And, ultimately,
we are going to want to
generate a mathematical model
for this titration.
And then, if you are
experimentalist,
you want to go ahead and take
that mathematical model and
compare it to actual
experimental data.
But let's work on getting a
model generated,
here.
First we are going to have a
set of chemical equations.
These correspond to the acid
HA, which is acetic acid in our
example, in water reacting to
give some concentration of H
three O plus plus the
anion A minus,
which is acetate ion,
in this particular case.
We have a strong base,
which is sodium hydroxide.
And when you put sodium
hydroxide in water,
because it is a strong base,
it ionizes completely.
And I am signifying that with a
single forward arrow rather than
with an equilibrium arrow.
This going into water is going
to be Na plus and
hydroxide, OH minus.
Now, at certain points in a
titration curve,
you would not need to
necessarily go much further than
this in order to have enough
information to start solving for
the pH at a particular value of
a volume m.
But at some points along that
titration curve,
that is not enough information.
And that is because water
itself can sometimes get into
the equation.
Here is an interesting
equation, which is H two O plus
H two O going to H three O plus
plus O minus.
That is a conceivable reaction
that could be occurring even in
pure water, but the value of the
equilibrium constant for that
reaction is very small.
And I will draw that as an
equilibrium to distinguish it
from the irreversible ionization
of sodium hydroxide in aqueous
solution.
I have a pair of equilibria
that I have written.
I have one forward reaction.
And I want to point out,
too, that this third equation I
have written here has a special
name, which is autoprotolysis.
I will tell you more about the
equilibrium constant associated
with autoprotolysis in a moment.
But because this equilibrium
constant is very small,
meaning that there is very
little H three O plus
and OH minus present in
pure water, because of that pure
water itself is not a very good
electrolyte.
Meaning pure water itself is
not a very good conductor of
electricity, because the
autoprotolysis reaction lies
mostly over here to the left in
pure water.
But at certain points along a
titration curve,
such as the one we are going to
want to develop on this panel
here, we are going to need to
include autoprotolysis in order
to get the right answer because
it is there, it can occur.
Let's continue.
Another type of equation that
we can use to put this into some
kind of a mathematical footing
is the balance of charge in a
solution like the one that we
are talking about in that beaker
to which we are adding sodium
hydroxide solution.
And the charge balance
consideration tells us that the
concentration of hydronium ion
plus the concentration of sodium
ion must be equal to the
concentration of hydroxide plus
the concentration of acetate
ion, A minus.
Because what I have done here
in the charge balance
consideration is I have said
okay, what are all the possible
charged species in solution?
I can make a list of them.
It is those four things.
And I know that the number of
positive charges must equal the
number of negative charges
because this is overall a
neutral beaker in which we are
putting things.
But everything that you put in
is charge neutral,
so the positives have to equal
the negatives.
That is a very nice limiting
equation that helps us
understand how the different
competing chemical reactions and
equilibria will all settle down
and arrive at the physical
result, which will be our
observable.
And then, in addition to that,
we have a mass balance
consideration.
And in this mass balance
consideration,
we will be able to write that
our HA initial value --
-- that is square brackets,
once again, denoting
concentration -- will be,
at any point in time,
equal to the actual value of HA
plus the concentration of A
minus.
And that just says that when
you have acetic acid and you put
it into water,
it ionizes partly to hydronium
ion and acetate ion.
And that which does not ionize
is unionized HA.
And so, the ionized A minus
concentration plus the
unionized HA concentration is
equal to the sum total of the
acetic acid that is present in
solution.
And, similarly,
we have another mass balance
equation, which is just that the
sodium hydroxide initial is
equal to our sodium ion
concentration because all of it
is ionized.
That is a little simpler than
the situation with the acetic
acid.
And then, in addition to those
equations, we have our
equilibrium equations.
And we are going to have two of
these because there are two
equilibria that I wrote over
there under titration equations.
The first of these is going to
have the equilibrium constant
Ka, and that is going to be H
three O plus times A
minus,
which is acetate in the case of
acetic acid, all over HA.
That is the expression for the
equilibrium of acetic acid
ionization in dilute aqueous
solution.
And I will give you a value for
this in a moment.
I won't write it right here.
Well, why don't I just do that.
It is 1.8x10^-5 for this
specific example of acetic acid.
And then, if you were working
with some other weak acid,
you would be able to go to a
table and look up the Ka value
for it, if it has been measured
and reported and tabulated.
And then, we have Kw.
And this is the equilibrium
expression for the
autoprotolysis reaction that I
mentioned over there,
the other equilibrium,
which is H three O plus times
OH minus.
And that is equal to 1x10^-14,
so a very small equilibrium
constant.
And some of you may be
wondering why water is not
appearing in an expression like
this one or like this one.
And the reason for this is that
in the expressions that I am
deriving here,
we are using concentrations in
place of activities for these
species.
In the derivation of the
equilibrium constants,
the activity of pure water at
very high concentration is
approximated as one.
And so, this is simplified as
shown here.
And having put all these
equations together,
what we are going to want to do
is take the following approach.
We are looking at the
expression for
electro-neutrality here,
the equal number of positively
and negatively charged species
in solution.
And I want to get this
expression rewritten in terms of
things that I know at any point
along the titration curve,
with the exception of the one
thing that I want to know,
the pH.
And the pH we can calculate
easily if we know the H three O
plus concentration.
So, I am going to be seeking to
get Na plus,
OH minus,
and A minus rewritten
in terms of H three O plus
and constants using
the equations that I have up
here on the board.
First, let's attempt to do that
for A minus using this
Ka expression.
And I am going to rearrange it.
And it is going to be equal to
Ka times HA divided by H three O
plus.
But I still have a problem with
this expression for A minus
because I am going to
need to replace HA with
something that will allow me to
get everything in terms of just
H three O plus and
constants.
And so, if I look over here at
the mass balance equation,
I can use this one and replace
HA with HA initial minus
A minus.
Now I have A minus
written in terms of an initial
concentration of HA itself and
constants.
I need to rearrange this a
little bit.
I am going to multiply through
by H three O plus so
that I can write A minus times H
three O plus is equal to Ka
times HA initial minus Ka times
A minus.
And hopefully I have done that
right.
And, if so, I will be able to
say that A minus is going to be
equal to Ka times HA initial all
over H three O plus.
Does that look good?
Plus Ka, thank you.
H3O+ plus Ka.
And let's bring
that down here.
Because now,
I would like to go ahead and
make this substitution for the
charge.
We have our A minus.
The other ones are a little
easier.
We now have this equation H
three O plus.
And we were going to replace Na
plus by NaOH initial.
And we are going to recognize
that we can use the equation for
autoprotolysis to replace
hydroxide with Kw divided by H
three O plus.
And then now we have the A
minus being replaced
by Ka HA initial all over H
three O plus plus Ka.
And at this point,
you have actually done a really
nice thing, because you have
generated a general titration
equation for the titration of
interest in this particular
case.
You can see that at any point
along that curve for a given
volume m, we can now stop and
walk along in one milliliter
increments.
And, in each spot along that
curve, we could go ahead and
solve this equation to get the
value of H three O plus.
And then we would just have to
take the negative log of that,
and we would have the pH at
that position.
And we are interested if this
type of a model for the
mathematical form of the
titration curve bears any
resemblance to what one sees in
reality.
And, if so, one could then be,
at least for the time being,
until your theory no longer
fits, satisfied that you have
accounted for the various
equilibria that could be present
in a system such as the one we
are describing here.
This happens to be a cubic
equation, and it has,
therefore, three roots.
And when we solve it at each of
these points along the titration
equation, because of the
physically realistic quantities
that we are going to be
interested in,
only one of the roots is
positive.
We are talking about H three O
plus concentration.
It cannot be a negative
concentration.
The positive root is the one we
want, and then we can convert
that to pH and can see what kind
of result we get.
And so, I will show you how we
can do that using a tool
available on Athena.
First of all,
let me tell you that for the
purposes of doing this,
I am going to replace these
various quantities by some
simpler symbols,
here.
I am going to go x plus a,
a is our NaOH initial,
is equal to (b over x) plus (c
times d) over (x plus d).
So, I am going to use those
simpler symbols for this
equation.
I could rearrange it and show
you how it is a cubic equation,
you set it equal to zero,
and then you solve,
and you get the roots.
Just like a quadratic equation
but with another term.
And, instead of doing that,
we are just going to leave it
in this form,
which is simpler to look at.
And we are just going to use
that.
And so, let's go ahead and
define A.
That is the initial
concentration of sodium
hydroxide.
We are going to go 0.1.
And remember I need to get this
in terms of the quantity m here,
which is the volume.
And so, I am going to take m,
minus 20 over m.
And the reason I am doing is
this is I am saying that we have
an 0.1 molar solution of sodium
hydroxide that we are adding.
But there is a dilution factor
that you have to take care of.
So, at every value m we are
saying that we are starting with
a volume of 20 in the acetic
acid flask at the bottom there
at the beginning.
And then we are starting to add
volume units of sodium
hydroxide.
And so the volume,
m, is increasing.
That is how I take care of
that, there.
And then our value of b is Kw,
so that is 1 E minus 14.
That is for autoprotolysis.
And then we have c,
that is our initial
concentration of acetic acid.
And we happen to have a
dilution factor here,
too, but it is simpler,
just 20 divided by m.
And there is that.
And then d, what did I say that
d was?
d is our equilibrium constant
for HA, 1.8 E minus 5.
There is our acidity constant
for acetic acids.
Now I have the four things in
there that I need,
and those are four things that
I know because of the initial
conditions that I am defining
for this problem.
And then I am going to define
my equation as being equal to x
plus a is equal to (b over x)
plus (c times d) all over (x
plus d).
There is my equation.
And this nice calculator,
all I have to do,
in principle,
is tell it what the value of m
is.
And then it is going to solve
that cubic equation,
give me back the three roots.
I take the positive one and I
take the negative log of it,
and then I know the pH at that
value of m.
I can develop a whole titration
curve based on the equations
that we have been discussing.
And so let's choose a value of
m here to start with,
and I am going to choose 30.
We are starting at 20.
At the very beginning of the
titration, we are at 20.
Let's see what happens at 30
given the particular value of m.
Here is what I do.
There may be other ways to do
this.
I am defining this thing called
the solution set.
Because the solving of that
equation is going to give us
three values.
And then I want to be able to
pick the one that I want.
We would use sol-set is equal
to, we are going to solve that
equation, and we want x,
which is our H three O plus
concentration.
And sometimes it chokes.
Let's see what happens.
Sometimes it is a little slow.
But it takes a lot longer if
you actually try to work it all
out by hand.
I have a picture of an image of
this that I grabbed.
I can show you if this fails on
me.
Don't fail on me.
There we go.
You can see it got the answer.
And so here is a positive root,
and then there are two negative
roots to this cubic equation in
x.
And I want to find out the pH.
When we are up to 30 volume
units, m equals 30.
And so, I will define p here as
equal to the negative log base
10 of the first of the answers
in my solution set,
sol-set one,
which is the positive x value.
And, bingo, there is the pH,
4.745 whatever dot,
dot, dot.
That is now the pH at a volume
of 30.
Now, you figure I am starting
with 20 volume units of 0.1
molar acetic acid.
And by the time m equals 30
volume units,
that means I have added ten
volume units of strong base,
enough to quench half of my
acetic acid.
And what if I had just only
quenched none of it?
I can change m now.
Once you have this in here,
you don't have to retype these
things.
I can go back here and say let
m be 20.
And, if I do that,
now I am actually at the zero
point, before I add any strong
base.
And there is the pH now,
2.87.
The answer to the expression
that we had at the very end of
class last time that was going
to tell us what is the pH of
tenth molar acetic acid,
there is the answer,
2.87, because that is what we
have when we start.
Now you can see that you could
just go through and use that to
get the pH at any value of m
along this titration curve.
And when you do that,
let's show you what the result
is, now what you see here is a
set of data.
I start at 20.
And I'm going up in single
volume units,
21, 22, 23, and 24,
I am showing what the pH is at
each of those choices of m.
And I have gone all the way
from 20 to 60.
And you take that data set --
And then you can take a file,
like the one I just showed you,
which just had values of m and
corresponding values of pH.
And you can go ahead and just
plot that thing.
And, when you do that,
you get the form of the
titration curve here,
which is the classic form of a
titration curve for titrating a
weak acid with a strong base.
And you see that here,
m was 20, and we let it
increment through all the way up
to 60.
And what you see initially,
and you are going to need to
study this one and the other
cases of titration curves that
are in that chapter of your
book, is how the little subtle
features differ from one case to
another.
They do differ.
A much simpler titration curve
than this one is obtained if you
titrate a strong acid with a
strong base.
This is titration of a weak
acid with a strong base.
And you see that initially,
we have that 2.87 initial pH
value, that it kind of shoots up
quickly here at the beginning.
There is a steep rise,
initially.
And then it kind of levels off.
And in this region here,
the pH is not changing very
rapidly at all as you are adding
more sodium hydroxide.
Until you get out here,
and the pH just shoots up.
And you will notice that it is
around where we get to 40.
Because we started with 20 mLs
of tenth molar acetic acid.
And, when we get out to m
equals 40, we have added 20 mLs
of tenth molar sodium hydroxide.
At that point the pH just
shoots up.
And then over here it turns
over and just goes kind of
slowly for a minute.
And it just approaches an
asymptotic limiting value over
here on the high pH side of the
scale.
One thing you will notice here
is that at this point where we
have added the same number of
equivalence of sodium hydroxide
molecules as we had acetic acid
molecules to start with,
this occurs over here at
greater than 8.0 pH units rather
than at the neutral value of
7.0.
And I would like you to think
about why that might be.
And that will be something that
will be covered in recitation,
but it is important.
If we had derived here today
the expression for the titration
of a strong acid with a strong
base, then at 40 we would be
right at 7.0,
but when we were using this
weak acid, acetic acid,
it comes up here over 8.0 pH
units.
This point where we have added
as many strong base molecules as
we started with,
weak acid molecules,
is called the equivalence or
the stoichiometric point in the
titration.
Moreover, where would your
indicator molecule change color?
At what point,
at what value of m,
for example?
It would be close to there.
It would be because,
in the case of phenolphthalein,
it changes between right in
here.
It might change right around
maybe 41 or so.
m equals 41 might be where the
color change from colorless to
pink occurs, for the reasons
that we have discussed.
And then right here,
it turns out at this value of m
equals 30, the pH is equal to
the pKa of acetic acid.
And that is a relationship that
I would like you to think about.
And it is a relationship that
comes into play very strongly
when we talk about the
preparation of buffer solutions
according to the
Henderson-Hasselbach equation.
At m equals 30,
the pH value of the titration
is the pKa of acetic acid,
which is right here at about
4.7 or so.
We did that one a moment ago.
We found out what that value
was.
And, in plus or minus 1.0 pH
units of that,
we have the part of the
titration curve that is called
the buffering region.
In here we have generated a
buffer in situ.
And buffers help the pH not to
change too much when acids or
bases are added in solution.
That is what buffers do.
They try to help you keep in a
constant pH range because lots
of things are dependent upon a
particular pH for proper
functioning.
And you know that this is
important in the world's oceans,
it is important in our
environment, and it is important
in our bodies.
So, the pH considerations for
aqueous solutions are quite
important.
And I hope that today I have
been able to give you a nice way
of thinking about some of the
math that goes behind a
titration curve.
Have a nice Halloween.